[Music]
Jihad watch every week with Robert
spener I've said this before and I'll
say it again if uh there is peace
between Muslims and non-muslims and
everyone gets along and there's no more
beheadings murders suicide bombings
oppression all that sort of thing
censorship then this segment of the show
will Disappear Completely until then
it'll carry on I think it's going to
carry on uh Robert Spencer always
pleasure how are you just great Michael
how are you I'm pretty well now let's
talk about Detroit both of us spend uh
bit bit of time in Michigan we don't
maybe not Detroit so much but we we do
go down there I was in Dearborne with
you at one point Dearborne Michigan
where the Islamic community want to uh
arrest all sorts of people for speaking
out against Islam in any way at all this
is fascinating though this is about uh
well an atheist ad uh that uh that went
up and and perfect right you know
atheists have a perfect right to don't
believe in God you're not alone
absolutely fine as long as other people
are allowed to respond but there seem to
be a bit of a double standard here this
one here don't believe in Muhammad is on
the screen You Are Not Alone the truth
about muhammad. comom did that actually
go up on on billboards no it was refused
ah uh it was an idea of my colleague and
our mutual friend Pamela Geller who uh
saw the atheist ads and wanted to test
the parameters of the freedom of speech
in Detroit because we earlier tried to
place an ad offering help to uh people
who were considering leaving Islam and
were under threat because of Islam's
death penalty for for apostates and
since that ad was refused and then we
won a free speech case about it but then
Detroit smart Transit appealed and we
lost the appeal and we're still fighting
that uh she wanted to test uh how much
how willing Detroit was uh going was
going to be in terms of uh free speech
in uh accommodating an ad that was uh
critical of Muhammad now they ran the
atheist ad no problem and they said well
it's free speech and so we have to do it
but they rejected our ad obviously
because they are afraid of a violent
response from Muslims in Detroit and are
thus submitting and cow to Violent
intimidation or just because uh it's not
permissible in Sharia Detroit nowadays
to criticize Muhammad now causing
offense should not be any sort of
criteria I'm offended all sorts of
things I'm also a grownup and a Democrat
and I I believe we have to tolerate this
sort of thing there are some mega
churches in Detroit gr Detroit and parts
of Michigan a huge for example black
christian community a lot of black
evangelicals and Pentecostals who will
be offended by don't believe in God but
okay they're offended big deal but it
still went up uh it's still a small
minority Muslim Community in in Michigan
but just because they apparently might
be offended and and and there was no
evidence that they would be I'm sure
they would have been but the the the
possibility they would be and the ad
wasn't accepted well yeah and this is
the other thing about it also that I
have to say is that they probably would
have been offended they probably would
have complained and whined and protested
if not reacted with violence but Michael
if you go to the truth about muhammad.
comom it's a it's an extract from my
book of the same name the truth about
Muhammad it is simply biographical
material about Muhammad that is from the
earliest Muslim sources and so they'd be
Tak offense about things that are in
their own canonical texts about Muhammad
and that is the weird thing about this
is that there seems to be a very great
unwillingness on the part of Muslims for
them to for for non-muslims to know what
is actually taught about Muhammad in
their own texts right talk about uh
Salman Rashi I I've known salon for many
years in fact uh my second book he was
one of the chapters we did a TV show
about him this is before satanic vers is
very aidite sophisticated man a
genuinely liberal man he does believe in
intolerance and freedom of speech now
there's still a fat sort of but he
travels widely but this was in in India
and the speech was cancelled because
there was a fear of an Islamic attack
yes uh and he was supposed to speak in
Kolkata and it was cancelled on the at
the request of the police and that's
what's really amazing about this story
Michael is that the police in countries
that supposedly protect the freedom of
speech ought to be going out of their
way to protect those who are threatened
for exercising their freedom of speech
and yet in this case the Indian
officials actually requested that rushin
not address the conference that he was
scheduled to speak at and so it's really
the kind of the same thing that's
happening in Detroit we have officials
who are not Muslim lining up to do the
bidding of Islamic supremacists and
enforcing Shia upon themselves out of
fear or political correctness or some
combination of the two right now let's
talk about this at greater length here
because I I do know South Asia and uh
people need to realize this I'm a a
Christian I'm a Catholic I'm not a Hindu
but Hinduism predates Islam by the
hundreds and hundreds of years this
country was overwhelmingly Hindu Islamic
armies came in and and conquered and
converted people generally by Force so
the Northern parts of the country is now
thought to be Pakistan and other areas
are a Muslim in India itself which is a
pluralistic country there are more
Muslim millionaires in India than there
are in Pakistan there is more freedom to
practice different parts of your Islamic
faith Sun Oria whatever than there is in
Pakistan the Islamic State at the same
time this this has to be reciprocal you
you have to tolerate Christians and
Hindus and Buddhists and siks but if
India is going to collapse if if if a
Hindu state is going to collapse in the
face of Islamic aggression we're in big
trouble Robert absolutely yes and it's
also very important to note that
Pakistan had a very substantial Hindu
minority at the time of the petition it
was something like 30 something perc and
now it's down to one or two% they have
systematically driven the Hindus out of
the country have persecuted them made
them subject to Violent attacks the
police don't care they don't help and in
India meanwhile Muslims are a protected
class who get these special privileges
and when they when they make violent
threats like against rushi in this case
then the Indian officials rush to give
them what they want in Pakistan there is
a blasphemy law and in prison there are
in fact there are more Muslims than
anyone else in prison under the
blasphemy law these are more secular or
liberal Muslims but also Christians and
and Hindus the approach I mean
Christians are given the the worst
possible jobs it's aing it's an apar
like system I mean the same people who
call Israel absurdly an aparte State
turn Blind Eye to the real aparti which
is applied to to non non-orthodox Sunni
Muslims in Pakistan I wish we had more
time Rob there's always so much to talk
about but believe me we will have you
back every week as long as I have this
show thank you my friend thank you
Michael always a
[Music]
pleasure K CER is next and the UN have a
great idea about feeding the poor we're
going to tell you more when we come back
it's absolutely fascinating
oh